this is the quality of my camera's audio
this is our $1,000 microphone quality
and this is the quality of the $180 lar
M2 and that's not even the best part of
it look how tiny this thing is it is
incredible and we actually just came
back from CES and this is the microphone
that we used and it did a great job and
we had so many people come up to us and
ask us what is that mic it's so small I
love it now my previous favorite mic was
the Lark M1 because of how nice and
compact it is you guys see that right
here but this new one it is even better
because it is magnetic so I have this
tiny capsule right here and it can just
magnetically connect to your shirt Your
Collar but they have a bunch of other
methods here now the case is right over
here it's a charging case as you guys
can see your little capsule just pops
right in and what I love love about this
thing is that you have your receiver
that charges as well and this thing has
a USB type-c output so you can connect
it to your Mac to your laptop it also
has a 3 and 1/2 mil output to connect to
your camera which is awesome and at the
top you have this little dial for your
volume adjustment and that is amazing
but with that most mics they just give
you one option this combo set actually
comes with a little receiver that plugs
into your iPhone with USB type-c bam all
you do is do that it will automatically
pair or you also get a lightning version
that you can also pop into a lightning
iPhone and the combo pack comes with all
of them now along with that the little
uh transmitters they automatically pair
to either one you don't have to go in
and repair it and you can actually take
one of these and just slot it right in
there to store and charge up now the
battery life on this is incredible we
actually charged it through USB type-c
before CES and the whole week we were
there we didn't have to charge it and
now it is still showing full bars it is
insane and the case is fairly small and
another thing I absolutely love and
respect is that even though we have the
hollyland logo on this tiny capsule they
actually give you this sheet of stickers
where you can cover it up with a black
little sheet like I have on this one you
have white and you also have some emojis
so you don't have to be walking around
with the logo of the brand of the mic
that you have or put tape over it that
is awesome another sweet thing is how
strong these magnets are you guys could
see it is just attaching right here and
actually you can go and bump the units
itself so these things are not going to
be going anywhere now with that if you
don't want to use this attachment method
they actually give you these little
clips that you can clip onto something
and just magnetize like that you get two
of those and you also get these
necklaces as well if you want to use a
necklace instead it will just attach
that point and if you lose that back
little metal piece you can actually pop
it out of here you have some extras so
hollyland gives you a ton of different
options with how to mount it now because
it's magnetic you can also grab anything
that's magnetic and attach it to it so
if you want to record audio from say a
speaker or somewhere else you just
magnetize it bam it is on you don't have
to be taping it to stuff like I've done
for years now with that you also get
these little muffs so that if it's super
windy you can slip them on and control
that but with that these actually have
noise reduction technology that we were
using so right now you guys might see
there's a little green logo I can
actually press this switch to Blue to
turn that off and another sweet thing is
if you're connected to your phone if you
double click this it will actually start
taking a video or a photo depending what
mode it is so if you're recording
remotely you can trigger your phone that
is just Genius of course you get a
charging cable with it but it uses
regular USB type-c you get a little
baggie to carry it in which we did take
with us they give you so much bang for
your buck now as I mentioned this is the
only mic that we use at CES and not only
is the capsule tiny and only weighs 9 G
the actual receiver is also tiny it's
powered by your phone and it weighs
barely anything so if you're using a
gimbal like we were it's not affecting
the balance now on it you actually have
a USB input as well so if you want to
pass through charging to your phone you
are able to do that now I know some
people will say you can use your airpods
instead and I want to say the Cs was an
incredibly tough situation there's so
much Wi-Fi and Bluetooth and
interference everywhere and these did an
insanely good job just go ahead and take
a listen to the comparison of using
airpods Pro 2 compared to this so right
now I'm using my airpods Pro which a lot
of people do use and it's okay but you
could tell the sound quality is not very
good and now we switched over to the
hollyland lar M2 and you guys could tell
that the audio quality is definitely
better and this is how it sounds if
you're just using your iPhone without
ation and obviously it is terrible
please don't it was so l at CES so we
are very thankful that this has noise
cancellation built in and as you guys
could see we have the app right here you
can connect to it right now I just have
one my capsule you get information about
it and with just that one click I can
remotely turn on that noise cancellation
and right here we're preset to week if
it's not too loud so like in this room
we'll get rid of all of your background
noise and hbac sound or you can just go
in and hit strong to change that and it
did way better than our airpods did
which just messed up the sound it had so
much interference now you can also
adjust the volume level and of course
it's going to automatically tune it as
well so it's so incredibly easy now one
other feature is Speaker play so a lot
of times when you plug in some kind of a
mic if you go back to check the audio
you have to unplug it in order for you
to be able to use the speakers this just
has it built in it just works so well
and while we're on the topic of noise
cancellation let me show you guys the
difference here here I'll play some
sound from our laptop this is what it
sounds like with noise cancellation
turned off and this is noise
cancellation set to weak and this is
noise cancellation set to strong so as
you guys see that was a big difference
now you can also update the firmware in
the app which is nice and another sweet
thing is that some brands that have two
transmitters one will record on left
side or right side this you can actually
go ahead and switch what it's doing do
want mono or stereo or it'll
automatically go ahead and do that like
it did at CES now the audio quality is
also very high it's 48 khz
24bit digital audio and they put a lot
of effort into the
anti-interference setup to help out with
really good range as well and even at
CES where many companies couldn't even
get their apps to connect to their
products there was so much interference
overall it did a killer job you guys
heard that the airpods they are
literally unusable where normally um you
wouldn't have any interference so for a
price tag of 180 bucks for this whole
set giving you the option for regular
cameras for computers for lightning and
use PC devices this is insane I've spent
thousands and thousands of dollars in
audio I've never seen something that is
as good of a deal as this I love their
previous version this new one is just um
just amazing I literally have nothing uh
negative to say about it such a killer
value so if you're into any kind of
audio creation video creation where you
need to have a microphone uh for gaming
setups connecting your computer go ahead
and check this thing out we'll leave the
links down in the video description the
hollyland Lark M2 is a game changer
especially for us here at maxtech thank
you guys for watching go ahead and click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those videos right over there
this been Max and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video